to do something that I love doing I love
building teams love the process of
solving the problems that's how much
love I have for this thing that I do I
love every minute of it really love to
do get involved in things that you love
you're so passionate excited and in love
with the love of putting words together
you got to love what you do I loved what
I was doing I decided what I was gonna
do a job I loved what I was doing I
would walk around I would dance and sing
as I was delivering my papers and that
kind of helped me to for the future of
what I wanted to do and now with just
being a young entrepreneur I thank God
every day that I'm blessed with the
chance to to do something that I love
doing but I feel anybody could do
something that that they love doing if
they if they go after it in the right
way if they go after with the love the
motivation for it is the love and the
love of leaving a legacy behind more
than the selfishness of just doing it
for money doing it to blow up to beat a
man at a woman but I have the fame if
you do it to make history if you do it
to change people's lives to make people
feel good to make yourself feel good
it's gonna come it's just gonna come
naturally you know I've always loved
technology and building things and
building products and 20 years into my
career and sure I don't need to work
anymore I got lucky on a couple of
projects to make a little bit of money
and that's nice but I love building
teams I love building products I love
building brands themselves so I love the
act of creating a brand like launch that
means something to people or inside comm
where people saying like you did like oh
you didn't gadget so for me I just love
the act of creating a brand and maybe
hopefully doing something innovative and
I think on my best day I'm able to do
that and on an average day maybe not so
much people that build great things in
any business anywhere they all have one
thing in common they love the process if
you start
a building or a company because it's
money you can't wait to get the building
finished you can have the cash flow
you'll get the building finished and
you'll probably have the cash flow but
if you love the idea of creating a
building you love the process of solving
the problems of digging into the details
of tearing up the paper and over and
over again revisiting a room a lobby a
restaurant to get it so that it really
feels good if you've got a passion for
process you're the kind of a person if
you're surrounded by good colleagues
then that's a team that produces
superior projects and and all of us at
Wynn Resorts we share that passion for
the process of creating these places and
so although we'd love the idea that they
end up being profitable for our
shareholders and it's given us all a
good life and I'm thankful for that
I'm really thankful for the idea that
I'm standing here today to walk you
through another project that we're dying
to build in a fancy city like Boston
first of all you have to make sure that
this thing is for you and it's who you
are and you're built for this you know
and then you have to give it the passion
that's necessary you know like I said I
don't do it for the money the money is
gonna come I do it because of the love
that I have for it you know I'm saying
if I was a plumber or something like
that I still would make hip-hop records
that's how much love I have for it you
know I feel like right now I've been in
the game close to 27 years and I've
actually thought about this just
recently out of the entire 27 my 27 year
career there's only been two weeks that
I've been out of the studio
there's no I've never been out of studio
longer than two weeks in my entire
career that's how much love I have for
this thing that I do and it's incredible
everyday to work with what I considered
to be the smartest and most innovative
people on earth and so I spend my day
working with those people on many
different things some things we didn't
talk about that you wanted to talk about
maybe and many things that that go with
running a company of
apple size and in all the geographies
that we're in it in and so forth and I
loved every minute of it it's an
incredible place to be it gives me it is
my oxygen so that's how strongly I feel
about it going in entrepreneurs need to
realize that sometimes it's not the idea
you know it's not beat it's not who you
know it's not how much money you have
access to it's really finding something
that you you really love to do I had no
idea I love computers and Technology
none I mean I took one class in Indiana
and computers and I cheated to get
through it it was Fortran and then I
bought a little PC in 99 for a from
Texas Instruments for $99 started
teaching myself to program and found you
know four hours later five hours later I
was I would look up and I've been
working this entire time and I loved it
and so that was the difference when I
finally thought I failed a lot of times
and I really I didn't know where I'd
find my success and then all of a sudden
I started playing with PCs and
technology and it just clicked my advice
is do things that are true to you you
know you know most things that I'm
involved with our extension of being
creative you know Rockaway is a clothing
company you know it's part of who you
are and hip-hop is your attitude and
what you're trying to express Express
how you dress thumbs you know I love
sports growing up I grew up in a
household where Sports was on 24th you
know seven so these are things that are
you know are comfortable for me you know
these are things that I like so I would
just say get involved in things that you
love and also have you know have a
standard for yourself and have some sort
of integrity and try to you know find
some sort of truth in what you're doing
you know I think that success in
business is a very difficult thing to
achieve and it's more difficult today
probably than any other time despite the
vast number of opportunities and as it
relates to finding your calling in terms
of what the opportunity or the
entrepreneurial adventure is going to be
it has to be linked to something that
you are so passionate and crazed about
that you're willing to knock down walls
and climb mountains and do the things
that are going to put yourself in a
position of sacrificing so many other
things for its success and you can only
do that when there's a compelling
underlying feeling that you have that
this is something I'm going to fight to
the death for and without that I think
it's gonna be a commodity based
experience not only for the customer but
for you and I think you can't really
succeed at the levels that you want to
unless you find that thing that you're
so passionate excited and in love with
and I think because you've got it along
the way you're gonna have to convince so
many other people to believe in you and
the idea and the opportunity and the
struggle and the obstacles that are
going to come can over only be overcome
by this passion that you have in which
you're going to be able to get people to
follow you over though over those
hurdles I know it sounds a little bit
sophomoric but it's so true me and
Bishop G made a pact by giving you don't
make it rapidly more to work at the post
office you know and it was like we
writing raps all day 12 hours a day come
go home you know stay up go to school
right to wrap this and wrap wrap the
wrap that you wrote the night before and
do that for the next 16 weeks type
situation so you know for me it's about
just the love it off you know the love
of putting words together you have to
love what you do and I'm not going to go
over that long but it solves a lot of
problems because when you love what you
do
would you really love what you do you
work harder I mean I have friends that
don't love and you know I tell this
story a Wall Street Titan big guy but I
was richer than him and I'm richer
according to Forbes are much richer than
him so I like that you know I like that
but there's big Wall Street Titan he's a
big name he has a son and his son is a
wonderful human being which is amazing
because the guy's a horrible a horrible
person but he's one of the biggest guys
on Wall Street so he wants his son Alex
I'm gonna use the name Alex
his name but I don't want to get this
guy in any more trouble with his father
than they already it's Alex isn't the
strongest character the father is a
brutal vicious killer so the father has
a big firm on Wall Street and he wants
Alex to go into the firm of course you
know come on Alex get in there get in
there
in the mean time all these kids are
graduating from Wharton and Harvard and
Stanford and they're just eating Alex's
lunch he doesn't have a chance
he doesn't have a chance and he doesn't
like it he's not liking what he's doing
you got to love what you do he's not
like him so one day but he can't leave
because of his father I actually tell
him why don't you leave your father's
brutal the father's just killing the
guys tell him you don't have what it
takes I'm sorry dad
oh this is great so I say you got to
leave the father you got to leave him he
said I just can't Donald Cerrone he's a
spoiled guy he's a member of a very good
Golf Club in Westchester which is a rich
place in New York and he's on one of the
committee's and he's on the greens
committee and they put him in charge of
redoing the course they're doing this
big renovation of the course it's a very
good cut Club and he's there every
morning at 5:00 in the morning he
doesn't leave he did such an
unbelievable job the contract is
respected him everybody respected him so
the wife comes up he's doing so great
Donald he's so amazing and they give him
an honor and this is a tough group of
people that have this look you know that
Club members and their difficult they
gave him an honor that Club came in
under budget faster by two months he did
an unbelievable job and the quality of
the work was ten times what they ever
anticipated so they gave him a medal I
said you know Alex you were to go and do
this for a living you ought to be a
builder whether it's houses or clubs or
golf courses renovation or this oh my
father would go crazy and never let me
so Alex went back to Wall Street where
he was miserable and a year later he
quit and he started doing renovations of
houses and clubs and different things
and he's doing great
so you've got to love what you do